it's 2020 and nintendo is once again
trying to kill melee
by sending a season assist letter to one
of the biggest tournaments of the year
nintendo is presenting a massive threat
to the future of their biggest esport
all right before we get into the video i
want to make sure that you know that if
you have a great idea for a new episode
of donate me or any series on our
channel you can send us that idea at
tips at the score dot com
and we also want to know that we're on
our way to 2 million subscribers so if
you haven't subs a channel please do it
already
what are you waiting for okay so last
week the big house a major super smash
bros melee and ultimate tournament
was forced to cancel their online event
because of a cease and desist letter
from nintendo
you might recognize nintendo from being
the publisher of super smash bros
according to robin haarn one of the
organizers of the big house nintendo
ordered him to cancel the event because
they were planning on using slippy
a fan mod for melee that gives a game
from 2001
better netcode than most fighting games
that came out in the last five years
october 29th i think is the first
conversation i had with
a nintendo rep and that's when the
conversations happened about
you know hey we understand you're using
slippy and that that's going to present
ramifications
and then i replied with
my decision i believe on november 1st
telling them hey i understand where
you're coming from but we're going to go
ahead as planned with the event
cease and desist november 18th so
it didn't take long between that last
conversation and
the actual c d now while slippy was only
being used for the melee part of the
tournament this does mean that the smash
ultimate side of the big house is also
cancelled
the whole tournament is gone because of
the cnd now if you don't know a lot
about melee or even if you do
you probably have a lot of questions
like why would nintendo do this
how could they do this what does this
mean for the future of melee
and why the [ __ ] is it called slippy and
i actually have answers to a lot of
those questions
first i should explain the slippy thing
because it's actually really important
basically earlier this year after
quitting his job and working on it for
years
a programmer called fizzy released
slippy which is a fan mod for melee that
gives it online play among other
features when it came out it was a huge
deal because it
basically let competitive melee exist
again in 2020 after all of this year's
tournaments were cancelled due to coven
melee is very accessible through slippy
more so than it has been in a long time
which is
super ironic because we are in a
pandemic right now
but slippy makes that possible because
you don't need to own a crt tv
which is a product that was discontinued
a decade ago there's there's certain
things that
um were barriers to entry that are no
longer
barriers which is why it's a beautiful
breakthrough that that happened this
year of all years so basically slippy
comes out and tournaments like the big
house one of the biggest tournaments in
the
world see a chance to get their
tournament back and run something online
now so far this has been going on
without a hitch slippy gives melee
better netcode than smash ultimate which
is insane because it's a free fan mod
for a 19 year old game
it's not exactly like playing with
people in person but it's pretty good
oh also it's called slippy because it's
named after that useless frog from star
fox
but then on thursday the big house
announced that nintendo had basically
shut them down
and that kickstarted a ton of
speculation and anger from the smash
community online
so why would nintendo do this well from
nintendo's perspectives there are a few
reasons
for one slippy only worked with emulated
copies of melee
and for most people that means
downloading copies of the game online
which is let's say less than legal uh i
will not pretend
to know the ins and outs of the legality
but
i believe it's more complicated than
just that but
the legal department at nintendo does
not see it that way like harm says
it's more complicated than just
emulation is bad it's perfectly legal to
have a digital copy of a game on your
computer and play it on an emulator
it's legal if you dump the files off the
disk it's just illegal if you decide to
distribute those copies to anybody else
now nintendo would argue that just
downloading melee off the internet is
illegal
which fair but then they would have to
prove that every copy of melee used in
the big house was illegally downloaded
and that's really hard to prove so they
just sent the cmd instead
but it's also possible that nintendo
doesn't have as much of a problem with
the files being illegal
as much as they have a problem with
slippy itself because nintendo has a
history of opposing fan mods in general
a few years ago game developer dan
salvato released something called the
universal controller fix which was a mod
for melee that smoothed out a few
very minor problems with the game in
order to put everyone on an even playing
field but in an interview with espn
esports then nintendo of america
president reggie fisime
said that nintendo opposes any fan mods
to melee at all
and behind the scenes a lot of
tournaments didn't run ucf because they
were afraid of pushback from nintendo
look whichever specific reason nintendo
sent to cease and desist it is all about
slippy which
feels ridiculous from the outside
looking at because here's the thing
there have been plenty of tournaments
running over the last couple of months
that used slippy and nintendo had no
issues with them
including smash summit 10 which was
running on the same day that nintendo
sent big house to cease and desist
so why did big house get hit and not
those other tournaments
well the answer is actually kind of
scary i don't know
um all i can share is that
i did receive a cnd we can speculate on
that on on why big house i
i haven't really invested mental energy
into doing that i don't find it
productive
the existence of slippy obviously
accelerated whatever stance they had to
take
on this if you copy and paste big house
with another event
that's just as big happening around the
same time maybe it happens to them i
don't know
yeah no one knows and that means that
anybody could get hit by a cease and
desist next
that's gonna have a real chilling effect
on anyone who wants to run a melee
tournament in the next couple of months
and i'll remind you that's the only way
to run a melee tournament right now
whatever the reason is nintendo can do
this
they have the exclusive right to shut
down any broadcast of their game
you might not realize it but every
publisher has that right any publisher
could step in and say don't stream our
game
very few exercised that right but
nintendo actually chose to do it in this
case
i think what's going on here is there's
people that
melee teos talk to from nintendo who
may actually understand where the
community is coming from and may
empathize with us
but they have to go to somebody higher
up and
that person probably has to go to
someone illegal at that point there's so
many degrees of separation
in the conversations that the person in
charge of making that final decision
of yeah we're going to see indeed this
event likely has absolutely no idea what
is
going on on the factory floor of a from
a to's perspective or from a player's
perspective in the melee scene so to
recap you need slippy in order to run
melee tournaments
nintendo sent the big house a season
assist for running slippy
that means that anybody could get hit by
a season assist for running a melee
tournament in 2020
that really sucks for the future of
melee and some of you might be saying
that all the smash community has to do
is wait it out because things will just
go back to normal after covet
and i'm just not sure that that's the
case we live in a content based
industry and without melee tournaments
on twitch
without vods on youtube without
high stakes competitions to drive
narratives in the melee community
it's going to be hard for that interest
to still be there
after a year plus of kovid i believe
the cease and desist potentially
represents an existential threat
to melee as a competitive scene and
that's why people should care about it
so understandably a lot of people are
pissed off about this
it's been said a million times how out
of touch nintendo is with the world
around them
and it should be said a million more
times because it is laughable how
archaic and primitive and disconnected
from reality nintendo
is and everyone right now
in a time when we don't know what's
gonna happen needs
this game they need that sort of escape
and for this to happen
it's not just wrong it's evil there's a
global pandemic going on
what is the alternative let the game die
they would love for that to happen
people actually got so pissed that free
melee was trending on twitter on friday
the idea is that if enough people spread
the word then maybe nintendo can be
pressured into reversing their decision
on big house or
at least not sending any melee
tournaments season assist letters in the
future
going back to the whole decision maker
thing clearly there's decision makers at
the top who
were out of touch with what the
community needed and how the community
functions
hopefully through social media and
general
exposure those people at the top can be
reached
that's the only way to potentially drive
change and there is precedent for
nintendo changing their mind
back in 2013 nintendo tried to shut down
the melee tournament at evo just days
before it was supposed to start
community backlash got intended to
change their mind and the tournament ran
without a hitch
so maybe that can happen again this time
but if it doesn't
things could be dire if this is a
one-off event
and all of the social media movement
can convince those decision makers to
back off then i think we can survive
this
if it set a precedent and there's
multiple cnds dropped
back to back on the next big tournaments
that are announced then i don't think we
can survive this
look i want melee to live as long as
possible and i certainly don't want
nintendo to kill it when it might be
about to find a huge new audience thanks
to online play
but i also don't know what anyone can do
but just hope nintendo listens
back in 2013 fan outcry gotten attention
to change their mind
hopefully this time they listen again i
do have hope
i think the melee scene just refuses to
die we're
we're just too passionate about the game
so um i
have always held out hope i think we'll
do it again
yeah well okay this is the latest entry
in
fan fixes the garbage netcode of
fighting game company gets mad
like it happened to street fighter with
the net with the roll with the netcode
patch
right it happened with i can't i think
it happens and then and then [ __ ]
capcom was like
mod it patched your game so you couldn't
mod it with the netcode patch anymore
which sucked
and then this ha and then this happens
this guy literally out of whole cloth
gives melee rollback netcode again a
game from before
that existed yeah and nintendo steps in
to say uh actually [ __ ] that
yeah the secret is that apparently it's
not [ __ ] hard
one person can it took him years right
i'm sure it's very difficult i'm sure
but it's like it's one guy working for
free you know what i mean
um one guy he has a patreon set up but
it's one guy not working for a company
just doing on his own
imagine how quickly an act like you know
a team of programmers could do this
call your friend right [ __ ] now get
on the i don't know if you still have
phones do zoomers still have phones
do you guys not have phones yeah you
guys all have a spotify
if you if you have a phone then call
your friend if you're in a discord voice
chat with like a million of your friends
right now because you're
waiting for wow or something tell them
all to sub to the channel if they
haven't already and if they haven't
stopped the channel and they refuse to
then why are they still your friend